[Music]
gamespot I'm Matt Padgett and today we
are at e3 2018 with Brian Wilson the
developer of where the bees make honey
how are you doing today and thanks for
having me
so we are you know excited to see your
game I've taken a look at it and I can't
wait to play it it reminds me of some
some of the puzzle games that I've liked
in the past and yeah why don't we take a
look at it so first off I really really
like the the style you're going for with
the like the photos and then these nice
pink red titles yeah so kind of where
the bees make honey is a 3d puzzle
adventure games during a young girl
who's usually dressed as a bee and that
kind of costume gives her the ability to
rotate the worlds in 90 degree
increments so which allow you to solve
the puzzles and explore further yeah so
this kind of it's just a marriage of
reflecting on this time when you were
young it's a little stuck yeah it's
reflecting on this time you were young
but from the perspective of an adult
when you grow up and things got more
serious so right now we're just in this
kind of tutorial area I'm just kind of
you're you're learning how to play
without me telling you how to play so
everything you're gonna do in the game
you just did right there awesome and is
is this the sort of kind of perspective
we're gonna be seeing for the rest of
the game or what exactly are we looking
at what type of game is this yeah so at
its core it is that kind of orthographic
isometric puzzle adventure game which
you're gonna kind of what you're seeing
now but in between each of the seasonal
levels is in a first-person gameplay
perspective if you're actually playing
as adult Sony so that's where I'm gonna
have a mix of gameplay in first-person
or maybe that remote control RC car you
had when you were young
just kind of flashbacks in between the
puzzle levels for sure you know it
actually looks really really beautiful
especially that last scene where you're
walking down the stairs and just the
lighting was just kind of revealing your
your where you needed to go what was
like the inspiration for these visuals
yeah so it's kind of that a it's kind of
a the liminality of transitioning from a
young girl to a woman or you know boy to
a man so it's it's that this stick is a
sword or maybe a gun so it's like you
can see you're still playing dress-up
it's still fun when you're that age so
kind of when you're in the jungle and
you're kind of seeking this treasure
you're steer exploring so there's
there's that kind of what exists outside
which may just be your backyard but in
your head it's this kind of cave and
just you know really ominous level yeah
and and and like speaking of like
ominous like these scenes these it I'm
guessing that's interspersed with like
real footage well how exactly were those
made yeah yeah so this is just a video
to kind of show you the relationship
between a hexagon and kind of a cube but
from a isometric perspective it's kind
of just like the marriage of shapes and
sacred geometry so cool yeah no it's
it's it's definitely striking but I'm
excited to get into and actually see the
I took a look at this game beforehand
and here we go this is a little more
familiar to me this is actually where
you're gonna so this is kind of our demo
for e3 we're showing at the the mix last
night so we just want people to actually
see the the core puzzle levels so it's
kind of this core rotation where you can
you're kind of seeing the world for just
from a different perspective by actually
changing your perspective so that was
kind of inspired by growing up in the
same small town and kind of having this
this lake but going to the lake at
different points in my life but I kind
of realized that the lake was always
there
but the lake stayed the same but by my
appreciation for it changed that's
because I was viewing it as I grew up
and that's kind of you know you you
can't you know the point is to kind of
get the three honeycomb pieces in each
level for the puzzles and you actually
have to turn it to see it so
everything's you know not clear to you
at first until you actually have to
rotate it and it's just kind of a your
view on life okay do-do the levels like
shift at all like is it actually like
changing the because I'm seeing you
going into this room here and then does
it you can't like could I walk around
that corner
blindly you can try it you can you can
definitely try but this is this being
kind of the tutorial of the the puzzle
levels it's supposed to be hey like okay
there's two I'm not gonna tell you that
there's three exactly at first but it's
a fact that okay let me just wait and
see what's gonna change and let me see
and literally well okay now I can see it
I'm kind of it's just kind of trial by
air and it's just kind of the the reward
of oh I did that I tried to do I tried
to find and search and I have a reward
now awesome so it definitely makes me
think of certain games what were there
any games that really like stood out to
you and made you think like oh this
really inspired me to make a puzzle game
in this way yeah at least not at first
so we have the winter level here at
least I didn't go into it trying to
remake a kind of game it's kind of that
that's where that this rotation mechanic
was inspired by that that kind of little
bit I talked about the lake and it was
about how can i play this two worlds
that I have to fit on the screen at all
times so you can basically see
everything
the camera doesn't doesn't exactly
follow you it just is all it's like kind
of just right here so now to your point
a little further back
is this one if you're kind of looking at
the ladder it's connected but now it's
not okay yeah so that's that's
definitely what I was wondering if if
the world would change as you move the
world around that's that is really
really awesome
thank you it's kind of it's supposed to
be you can't die you can't there's no
enemies Italy in these levels we're
about to hit a little bit of a secret
exclusive secret is all right get it
ready everyone you can only get this
kind of content at GameSpot right right
but no it's uh it's kind of you're
supposed to be it's like a crossword
puzzle but visual um so you're gonna be
able to rotate and just see what changes
and kind of try but not be you know not
be you don't you don't there's no fail
state there's no timer you don't fall
off so you can try these things without
having the pressure and and that's why I
want these worlds to feel so alive and
have animals and dynamics and kind of
weather elements that makes it feel like
a place that I want you to be here and I
want you to enjoy it I can definitely
get into that so yeah that was the main
thing I was wondering was like could
someone pull off a sick like I'm gonna
do this without rotating the world but
at least in that no you you can't it's
just no it's not possible
so that's awesome i I'm really into the
look of this game too it's it's
absolutely gorgeous and so you are a
solo developer does that mean you did
all of the art everything you see here
did you take these photographs as well I
did yeah so I've been solo developing
for the past year and a half the kind of
the photography it's kind of so within
games it's kind of applying what you
know and then filling in the rest with
what you don't know so that maybe other
people the community the asset store so
at least like I said in between these
levels it's going to be different kinds
of gameplay and
Maddox but it's like what do I have I
have I have photography you know and
it's about applying it and it's like
that's what indie games are it's it's
kind of these rough around the edges
maybe too bright maybe too loud but it's
it's so there's something raw about that
that I can make a specific game and have
it just exist and have it connect with
people so and right now you're you're
kind of seeing the the kind of the
dynamic lighting that's awesome I I
really really connect with that as
someone who came from a somewhat small
town and definitely like you you grow up
your view of the world starts to change
I can definitely connect with that how
about you you show me this puzzle and
then let me know where I can pick this
game up and when perfect yes so let's
just let's finish this so kind of you
know I could stand on this but if I turn
and I'm gonna fall off so it's again
you're gonna fall off but you won't
exactly get hurt so let's let's get to
this last one
perfect so where the bees make honey
we'll be releasing in spring of 2019
we're shooting for PC first and consoles
right after any consoles been
particularly tend to switch ps4 Xbox
hopefully ps4 Xbox first and then you
know the switch awesome thank you so
much for joining us that was where the
bees make honey and I'm very glad to
have met you Brian Wilson awesome have a
great day ma'am